[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
o.j simpson refuses to pay how much the
juice still owes to the families of his
slain ex-wife
and her boyfriend and why the case is
still being litigated in court
convicted wife killer scott peterson
remains on death row
after his death sentence was thrown out
but will peterson get a new trial for
the murders of his wife and unborn son
he is anxious to get back into court
roberts durst friends testify against
him in court the millionaire on trial
for his best friend's murder
and why the judge who presided over
durst's first murder trial
is speaking out all three of these
deaths are so connected
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
o.j simpson may be a free man living in
las vegas
but he's still fighting legal battles in
the courts law and crimes anjan levy is
here with simpson's latest effort
to keep from paying a judgment and a
decades-old wrongful death case
angenette
yeah brian a jury found o.j simpson
liable for the deaths of his ex-wife
nicole brown system
or nicole brown simpson rather and her
friend ron goldman
decades ago he was ordered to pay 33.5
million dollars but to date he hasn't
paid
a cent now the goldman and the brown
families
particularly ron goldman's father fred
have fought for years to get simpson to
pay and he has avoided doing so
now the families are in court in nevada
asking that any settlement
simpson may have received from a hotel
be given to the families
simpson sued the cosmopolitan hotel for
defamation in 2019
claiming that the hotel employees made
defamatory comments about him to a
website
after an incident at the hotel the case
was resolved earlier this year although
it's not known whether the hotel paid
simpson
any money at all simpson as you know has
claimed he's innocent of the murders and
was acquitted in his criminal trial
but it was a much different outcome in
the civil case
in the civil trial it became
even clearer that oj simpson
absolutely did it the fact that
there were these very unique shoes these
bruno molly shoes
very large size that
were in bloody footprints at the crime
scene
and o.j simpson in the civil case said i
never would have worn those other
shoes and yet lo and behold they find a
buffalo bill's newsletter
from nine months before the murder
and there's oj wearing the ugly shoes
there is
nothing more incriminating than that
now simpson's attorney has filed
documents with the court saying that he
will appeal any order that says that
simpson is required
to pay out any money whether it's from a
hotel settlement or anything else
he plans to go to the nevada supreme
court if needed
and the amount of the judgment has
actually ballooned over the years to 60
million dollars
brian thanks ange joining us today is
legal analyst dina dahl
and terry austin dean as i look at these
cases it brings a whole new meaning to
is the juice worth the squeeze if they
can't get the money from oj then how the
courts gonna get it out of him
well they're gonna have to just keep
trying and i think this is not unique
to the oj case in any civil suit it is
up to the person to go after
the person for the money versus these
liens and
that takes a lot of money in itself
going to court over and over and over
but that's what the goldman family has
to do
because anytime oj simpson may have
money
they have to try to go to court get a
lien against it
take this kind of action and so it shows
really the diligence of the family that
they continue to go after it
even though right now there doesn't
apparently be any money
and possibly some from this judgment but
nowhere close to where the settlement
amount is
yeah and they did a similar action when
he came out with this book if i did it
and that maybe got a little bit more
traction terry do any of oj's arguments
for not paying makes sense to you
or is this just one big stall tactic i
think it's a stall tactic because
they're avoiding payments and they've
been doing this for
almost 25 years the original award for
the wrongful death
of nicole brown simpson and ron goldman
that was back in 1997
then in 2000 we saw that oj moved to
florida
because he wanted to avoid paying that
judgment and now that we might have this
settlement for this defamation suit
we're seeing that his lawyers are
refusing to pay they are refusing to
even say
what the amount was on that settlement
claiming that it's confidential so
i think it is a stall tactic and i think
we're going to be seeing this
for a very long time make sense
anjanette have the goldmans and browns
ever received
any money in the settlement nothing that
amounts to anything brian you mentioned
if i did it that was the book that many
people regard
um as o.j basically a confession from
o.j
simpson he wrote that back in 2006 the
goldman
and brown families protested when that
book was going to come out
o.j simpson had received an advance for
that then the goldmans got the rights to
the book
and actually had it published themselves
the brown family was very upset about
that there's now a rift
so if i did it and a little bit of extra
other money is really all they've ever
gotten nowhere near 60 million
all right we'll see how this continued
battle goes for o.j simpson paying
off these settlements thank you all now
to colorado where a jury has been
selected in the trial
of a father accused of murdering his 13
year old son
dylan redwine vanished over thanksgiving
weekend in 2012.
in 2017 a grand jury indicted mark
redwine
for second-degree murder and child abuse
resulting in death
according to court documents dylan
reportedly found compromising photos of
his father
including him wearing women's clothing
and eating feces from a diaper he was
wearing be sure to tune into law and
crime network for capital gavel coverage
and in california a judge is denying
bail for a man
accused of killing a child during a road
rage shooting prosecutors say marcus
anthony eres is a complete danger to the
community ires is charged with firing
the shot that killed six-year-old ayden
leos
as his mother drove him to kindergarten
last month the california highway patrol
says ires fired a gun from his white
volkswagen
as his girlfriend when lee drove along
the freeway in orange county
lee is now being held on five hundred
thousand dollar bail
and in new mexico a man has been
arrested and charged with the murder of
his wife
who has been missing for more than two
years dane kalungi was taken into
custody in new mexico
after he tried to get into kirtland air
force base he is charged with
first-degree murder of his wife
gepsia maga kulungi who has disappeared
in march 2019.
the two met online and fell in love
which prompted jepsey to move to the
united states from the philippines in
2017.
they were married that same year in july
gypsy's mother told a local news outlet
that kalungi told her that he thought
his wife was going to the philippines
mexico or chicago to visit her friends
still ahead on law and crime daily
what's next for convicted wife killer
scott peterson
but first inside the courtroom for the
robert durst trial why friends of the
millionaire real estate air
are being called to testify against him
the testimony you won't want to miss
next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back the state of california vs
robert durst trial
is continuing with video testimony from
a longtime friend of the millionaire
real estate air
durs is accused of murdering his best
friend susan berman in december 2000.
prosecutors say durst believed berman
threatened to go to the authorities
with information about durst's missing
wife kathy
emily altman's husband worked for durst
as an attorney when he was arrested in
2001
for the death of his neighbor morris
black durst was acquitted of black's
murder but later pled guilty in
connection to chopping up black's body
on direct examination altman found it
difficult to admit that she would want
durst to be found guilty
if he had committed this crime she even
got emotional when asked about her
friendship with bob durst
as you said
so again if you can please answer this
question i'm asking
if he did what he's accused of
do you want him to be convicted
if if he's proving
to to do what we're accusing him of
then i guess
the pre-recorded testimony from altman
continued in court
where prosecutor john lewin questioned
her if she asked her friend bob durs
what happened that night that kathy
you would disappeared have wanted to ask
him the personal question
in trying to help him hey what happened
that night
no i didn't ask you what happened that
night first you asked me something about
i wish i had your question but no i
didn't
ask him that's just not me okay i asked
her for good health
i asked him for
[Music]
judge susan chris presided over the
texas trial for the death of morris
black
she spoke to law and crime about why
altman's testimony is so important
while durst was in jail in pennsylvania
and having recorded calls
with stuart and emily all the time
stewart
did a favor for bob he went
to new orleans and he took care of
something
he removed something and he took care of
it
and bob bought a fancy car for them i
can't remember if it was a lexus or
cadillac
but it was some very expensive car that
stuart wanted
and after the task was done the car was
bought
but there were so many things that he
said that were incriminating and that
showed
consciousness of guilt and a desire to
fool the jury
and he practiced testimony he had um
cassette tapes that he practiced his
testimony on
and gave to the altmans to let them go
listen so they could
decide whether or not he sounded
convincing and whether he should change
his story and i believe his wife might
have listened to them too
and he he bought a book about uh jury
psychology
and he did so much to prepare and at one
point he told his wife during those
tapes
to go watch the movie primal fear or
someone pretended to be crazy
and and killed someone and he was
thinking about
basing his defense on that movie
back with us illegal analyst dina doll
and terry austin terry another one is
being questioned about whether or not
they would have
asked a question and if they remember uh
that question at all do you think lewin
is getting what he needs out of altman
i do think loon has made some points
with altman and
one of the points that he made with her
is the fact that
she is extremely loyal to durst no
matter
what i mean he established the fact that
altman
had durst become the godfather of her
son
even after kathy disappeared in
1982 even after berman's murder in
december of 2000 and even after
black's death which she knew about and
the dismemberment in september of 2001.
so even after all of those events
altman still made durst
the godfather and the other substantive
point i think that was made here
is the fact that loon was able to
establish
that durst was in california at the time
of
berman's death and he established that
through altman so he's made some points
here
now dina a lot of these questions are
are asking
what is durst's state of mind but do you
think durst will be able to testify his
way out of another conviction if he
takes the stand
i don't think so i mean he obviously did
a great job of testifying and
not getting the conviction of a murder
charge but it's kind of like
third time a charm for anybody who wants
a conviction here how many times can you
talk yourself
out of a really bad situation plus we
have all this
testimony he gave during the documentary
and we know
public opinion then was very much
against it
here the prosecution has a chance upon a
very methodical case
which they are they're going to include
the documentary evidence
i don't see how he's going to talk his
way out of this unless there's something
clear
out of the blue sky that we just haven't
seen yet
we'll see the defense already said that
durst is going to take the stand and i'm
sure that lewin
is waiting for that day uh we'll
continue with that coverage and talk
more about that case
in just a moment coming up on law and
crime daily why scott peterson is
feeling anxious
as a judge decides if you'll get a new
trial plus more on the robert durst
trial
could the last words the victim told her
hairstylist about her best friend be a
major clue
find out ahead
back now to our continuing coverage of
the robber durst trial victim susan
berman's hairstylist took the stand
to say she was financially strapped
before she died but
was expecting money from her dear friend
bobby
there came a point where she could not
pay me but i told her not to worry
that when she got up on her feet and was
working again
and she could start paying me again
how long of a period approximately was
it where you were
not being paid yeah i'm sure you
remember well it was a few years
i'm sorry it was a few years i wasn't
getting paid
and she would say to me you know i'm
expecting a check from bobby and
i'll give you some money as soon as i
get that
you remember her telling you that the
money wasn't coming fast enough from
bobby
yeah and that was in this last
discussion you had with her
yes when she was saying that the money's
not coming fast enough from bobby
what was her demeanor like was it normal
was it different this laughs were gone i
mean
i could tell she was under a lot of
stress
she was very upset and she didn't know
where she didn't get her rent money and
uh things like that
all right let's bring in legal analyst
dina dahl and co-host terry austin
terry a down and out susan berman gets
help from durst in exchange for a favor
could this be burma's motive that the
prosecution is looking for to tie it all
together
absolutely you know money is always a
good motive behind
a murder actually there's no good motive
for murder but money is usually behind
it
and there are two viable motives here
one
is that durst did not want to continue
paying berman
but the other motive that i think lewin
and the prosecution all together
are making a good point at is the fact
that
clearly they wanted to durst wanted to
silence berman
and not have her talk about what she
knew as far as kathy's death was
concerned so i think these combined
motives of money and this secret that
durst wanted to keep was good now dean
the prosecution's case is being built on
one motive on top of another is the
complexity of this case
do you think gonna help or hurt the
prosecution
i think it's gonna help i mean it is a
little bit of a long
drawn-out process but it's also
fascinating i imagine the jury is right
there with the prosecution
it's they build so many blocks it
becomes
that how even if you have doubt how can
it be
reasonable doubt he's connected to so
many disappearances and murder
plus we know he's going to be admitting
to the fact that he wrote the note so he
was there at the time
that she was dead absolutely thank you
both when we come back
the legal hurdles in the scott peterson
case when the convicted wife killer will
be re-sentenced and whether he might get
a new trial
everything you need to know next
welcome back scott peterson's hoping for
a new trial in the deaths
of his wife lacey and their unborn son
law and crime's angina levy is back with
the latest in this 18 year old saga
yeah brian scott peterson was on death
row for the deaths of his wife lacey
peterson
and their son connor who had not yet
been born but an appellate court found
that there were errors in the original
sentencing
and that peterson should be re-sentenced
now the stanislaus county district
attorney
she could have pursued the death penalty
yet again but decided not to
this time around after meeting with
lacey peterson's family
so when peterson is resentenced he will
automatically be sentenced to life
without parole
but there's still the issue about
whether peterson will get an entirely
new trial
peterson claims juror rachelle niece
nicknamed strawberry shortcake by the
media came into deliberations
with a clear agenda to convict peterson
and we feel very strongly that under the
law
scott peterson like any defendant he has
the right to 12 independent jurors
each one independent and even if one of
them
has a prejudged notion and has decided
ahead of time
what decision they're going to make even
if it's only one that's enough to
overturn
and i believe that's what we have here
but obviously that'll be up to the judge
to decide
that was attorney pat harris he is now
representing scott peterson he was
actually part of the original defense
team back in 2002
2003 2004 when scott peterson was
charged
with the murders and he is going to be
representing peterson at taxpayers
expense the public defender's office
typically would have been doing that but
that office has a conflict
brian thank you and jeannette we're
expecting some more news this week from
peterson's legal team right
yeah it relates to that issue with the
alleged durham misconduct
peterson's appellate team had filed
what's called a writ of habeas corpus
and they are expected
by thursday to file some documents
related to that juror misconduct issue
with the court now dina august 25th will
be a big day for peterson
but it looks like evidentiary hearing or
retrial so is this a good place
for the peterson team it's a great place
because everybody
would want to have a chance to get it
overturned and that's what's happening
here
most likely my guess is that if the
judge
does think that the court filings has
some sort of merit she's going to ask
for an evidentiary
hearing and we may hear from the juror i
do not see her granting him a new trial
just based on filing alone
yeah we'll see how that hearing goes of
course we've got we'll have it covered
for you here at law and crime
and terry judges can never really reveal
what they're thinking with these
decisions but
they're humans just like the rest of us
and sometimes can
give little subtle clues as to where
they're leaning where do you think this
judge is leaning in this decision
well actually brian i just think based
on what she said that she might be
leaning towards granting a new trial
i mean she's willing to listen to the
evidence she said that if the habeas
corpus petition
is strong enough and it might merit a
new trial she would do that
she said if she's not convinced on that
that she's going to request an
evidentiary hearing which means
she wants more information and that
would include
witnesses testifying so she wants to
hear the evidence and she wants to make
sure she's making the right decision
i don't think she's going to come to any
snap decision so i think we're going to
be seeing
evidence and listening to this petition
one way or the other i will say this
she also said that she thought scott
peterson needs to come
to the hearing to be there in person and
that covett is not an issue right now
so i think she wants to see peterson
himself
and read his body language and make a
decision
based on all the evidence and also based
on scott peterson himself
yeah terry that last point was the one
that kind of raised an eyebrow for me
because usually
a judge wants the defendant there when
major decisions are going to be made
and so i was thinking is this just
coveted getting better or are you going
to make a major decision
i don't know but thank you all uh for
contributing and thank you for joining
us here at law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you